[Music]
olivia rodrigo slays on the grammy stage
giving a stunning performance of her
debut single driver's license i feel
very lucky to be able to do this yes the
19 year old singer rocks her signature
style in a white ruffled dress and
platform black boots complimenting her
look that vintage mercedes from the
music video
[Music]
oh my god i'm gonna be so nervous but
hopefully it'll go up without a hitch
i've just watched the grammys
religiously since i was so young and
just to be here and perform up on that
stage is just
such an honor well olivia those nerves
didn't show one bit you said forever now
i drive alone
past your stream
driver's license is a special song for
many reasons not only is it her debut
single but it's also the song that
earned her her first ever grammy award
best pop solo performance
[Music]
but get this olivia is already thinking
about the future telling e.t the artist
she's dying to work with next brenda
carla is performing tonight and she's a
big inspiration i think she's incredible
songwriter so i'm excited to meet her
bye
in the meantime olivia is keeping busy
the good for you singer is getting ready
to embark on her first ever tour and
this all follows the release of her
disney plus documentary film driving
home to you how would i describe this
chapter of my life
yeah it feels amazing we worked really
hard on the film and
i said it before but i'm going on tour
actually like literally the second we
finished the grammys i'm going on tour
and so i wanted to give my fans who
maybe um wouldn't be able to make it to
a concert uh something that they could
watch for a you know a little bit of new
content so i'm happy that we did that
you